every year we lose about 23 species that
are gone forever
and using this technology i think that
we can preserve and save those species
that have been lost
scientists at the university of georgia
are attempting to use dna from
endangered cats to save them from
extinction
what we're trying to do here is collect
skin cells from endangered species and
actually turn them into sperm or eggs
the goal is to develop a tiger embryo
and artificially inseminate a house cat
which will then give birth to a baby
tiger
because of the extensive knowledge of
domestic cats reproductive systems the
risk of failure is significantly lower
than if using a tiger as a surrogate
we know that we're going to have a lot
of hurdles and so what we want to do is
start off with an animal we know very
well and so we thought cats was a good
starting point
the three-part process of creating an
artificial embryo begins with collecting
skin cell samples from endangered
species
we got these samples from zoo atlanta
they collected the biopsies from their
sumatran tiger and their clotted leopard
those skin cells are then turned into
stem cells which will later be
reprogrammed into sperm and eggs
allowing for the creation of an embryo
once we have these sperm and eggs we'll
combine them together we'll get a
developing embryo and then the idea is
we're going to transfer them into a
domestic cat
and hopefully in a few months we'll have
a number of kittens from that individual
one of the greatest challenges that the
team has faced has been developing the
technique to transform skin cells into
stem cells a necessary task that they
have yet to accomplish
we are still waiting to make that leap
from skin cell to stem cell and i think
we're finally on the doorstep we're
ready to go
by collecting and freezing skin cell
samples from various animals scientists
are effectively providing a road to
bring back species that may become
extinct in the future
in a single tank you could have a
biobank of two 300 different species and
enough individuals in each box where you
could use this technology to repopulate
lost species
i'll never give up essentially as long
as i can keep doing great science and
exciting things
i just really think endangered species
are important to conserve and they're
worth the effort